c'est dans ce prêt en bord de loire
qu'alain ramo a découvert le carnage
samedi matin au milieu de la trentaine
de bêtes du troupeau
une carcasse à terre une vache de près
de trois ans portant un veau abattue
d'une balle
l'animal a été découpée sur place ses
quatre pattes ont été emportés on
n'avait pas des animaux pour retrouver
jean de carnage quoi surtout que c'est
une vache qui allait bel énormément et
demi on a retrouvé le veau à côté parce
qu'évidemment lorsqu'ils n'ont le volant
au moment du chargement mais il est
tombé assez bas ben quoi c'est pas c'est
pas notre métier la vache a
manifestement été abattus pour sa viande
un acte que craignez alain rameaux de
pique une de ses bêtes avaient déjà été
agressée à l'armé à feu
l'assurance devrait prendre en charge
une partie de la perte mais en pleine
crise de l'élevage c'est un préjudice
supplémentaire pour l'exploitation
c'est encore ça en plus et où c'est le
plus le plus grand préjudice c'est que
maintenant on n'arrête pas d'y penser
est bon on fait prendre notre travail
d'éleveur en allant voir nos vaches leur
donnant à manger on les soignants on va
dire ben attia est ce que je vais pas
trouver encore quelque chose ou voilà
donc c'est toujours inquiétant
donc ça souci supplémentaire mais
effectivement il ya une perte financière
mais c'est pas uniquement cela manipuler
un animal de près de 700 kilos a dû
nécessiter la complicité d'au moins
quatre ou cinq personnes
une opération préméditée et un mode
opératoire qui indigne les défenseurs
des animaux
c'est quelque chose d'assez inimaginable
que des êtres humains puissent décider à
plusieurs reprises ont tué plusieurs
forcément aller abattre une vache dans
son pré et ensuite de la découpe et
c'est quelque chose d'absolument
abominable on est sous le choc est
difficile de comprendre ses façons
d'agir
les coupables s'ils sont retrouvés au
cours d'une peine de cinq ans de prison
pour vol en réunion
l'enquêté a été confiée à la brigade de
gendarmerie de fourchambault